c'est derrière le volant de sa Mercedes
noire que Leonardo risuto a
miraculeusement survécu à une rafale
d'une dizaine de balles tirée pour le
toucher mortellement blessé à la jambe
par un projectile cette ironiquement
dans un salon funéraire qui l'a trouvé
refuge l'attentat contre Léonardo
résultats démontre sans l'ombre d'un
doute l'instabilité de la mafia la mafia
se cherche un leader crédible selon le
spécialiste André sedilo qui a signé
deux livres sur la mafia sicilienne
Leonardo le dernier fils vivant du
défunt parrain Vito risuto a été
propulsé au sommet du crime organisé
uniquement à cause de la renommée de son
nom de famille Léonardo
n'a pas la crédibilité dans le milieu
des au sein des familles mafieuses ok il
n'a jamais eu hors pour répliquer
rapidement Leonardo risuto devra trouver
les Alliés nécessaires et vétérans du
clan sicilien les plus influents sont
tous tombés sous une balle la tentative
de meurtre rappellerait que les
différentes organisations criminelles
veulent depuis longtemps tourner la page
sur le clan risotto au milieu des années
2000 on disait que les résultats étaient
plus les bienvenus même si l'affrolle et
la mort il serait surprenant que
Léonardo risotto s'enfuit à l'extérieur
du Canada comme le ferait plusieurs
mafieux normalement là il devrait
annoncer sa retraite mais je pense que
la c'est sûr que c'est sûr que Leonardo
résultats ne quittera pas le Québec
c'est donc davantage un symbole qui a
été attaqué par le crime organisé c'est
quand même assez majeur parce qu'on est
face à un individu qui porte évidemment
un nom de famille il y a eu plusieurs
personnes de sa famille de son entourage
qui ont été assassiné la suite des
événements fournir à la réponse aux
policiers ici Pascal Robida Radio-Canada
Montréal